bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
journal de la rédaction de tv fil 78
le point sur l'actualité est local tout
de suite les titres de ce lundi de ce
mardi 23 juin 2015
elle les parents d'élèves de trappes
mobilisés contre la réorganisation des
rythmes scolaires la suppression de
l'étude après l'école et la fin de la
gratuité pose des problèmes le dernier
conseil municipal a été agitée lundi
soir le département des yvelines investi
5 millions d'euros par an pour les
équipements sportifs le point avec
alexandre joly vice président délégué
aux sports du conseil départemental
invité du journal et puis deuxième volet
de notre dossier consacré cette semaine
à l'europe ce soir focus sur le service
volontaire européen le s v e paris selon
ce dans une nouvelle candidature pour
les jeux olympiques en 2024 ce midi le
premier projet a été dévoilé candidature
à 6 milliards d'euros et qui fait
émettre des réserves à certains la
candidate aux régionales en
ile-de-france valérie pécresse pour les
républicains souhaitent d'abord une
garantie quant au développement d'un
réseau de transport
d'autres comme jean luc mélenchon à
l'extrême gauche s'y opposent fermement
en raison d'un coût jugé trop élevé quoi
qu'il en soit saint quentin en yvelines
est associé au projet avec le vélodrome
que vous avez aperçu mais aussi le golf
national de sites qui vont donc
accueillir potentiellement qui peuvent
accueillir des épreuves verdict pour la
commission olympique en juillet 2017
que pensez vous de cette candidature de
paris pour 2024 c'est notre question du
jour
la candidature bas ça peut être une très
bonne chose économiquement maintenant
fonctionne bien géré on a connu des djo
mal géré ça peut être dangereux c'est
bien pour paris je pense
après ça coûte de l'argent mais c'est
bien aussi pour sainteny ça va peut-être
rapporté spall du monde des nouvelles
infrastructures c'est pas mal d'autres
bien oui oui oui bien sûr
je suis pas sportive alors pour ça m'est
égal 1 mais bon j'espère que nos impôts
ne vont pas à grimper en flèche très
bonne chose
maintenant c'est on a le temps encore
c'est un peu loin mais je pense que
c'est une bonne chose pour tout ce qui
peut être dans le développement dans la
région parisienne et le reste photo je
trouve ça très bien parce que c'est le
pour la france et c'est quelque chose
qui est bien qui est positif et c'est
très sympa et ça peut donner le travail
et certaines personnes c'est et c'est
positif on quitte le monde olympique le
conseil municipal de trappes c'est et
hier soir et la séance a été plutôt
mouvementée une trentaine de parents
s'est déplacé en mairie pour protester
contre la suppression de l'étude après
l'école et la fin de la gratuité pour
les activités périscolaires le conseil
municipal a finalement adopté ces
mesures pour la rentrée prochaine en
septembre sur place nickel et demi
d'euros et patrick jacques de dixmude
tension conseil municipal deux trappes
hier soir les parents d'élèves des
écoles primaires de la ville sont venus
en nombre pendant la séance
la raison ils protestent contre la
suppression de l'étude après l'école et
la fin de la gratuité de la tranche
horaire de 15h30 à 16h30 dès la rentrée
prochaine
selon les parents d'élèves ces mesures
vont une nouvelle fois pénaliser les
enfants savoir qu'une suppression de
l'étude pour des enfants qui restent à
lait ou aux activités jusqu'à 18h30
ça veut dire les devoirs après 18h30
pour d'autres familles ça se veut dire
que 20 des familles qui n'ont pas
forcément les bonnes méthodes ou les
acquis pour aider leurs enfants dans
leurs devoirs seront également
pénalisées pendant la séance le débat
était houleux entre les parents d'élèves
et la municipalité
le conseil municipal a finalement adopté
les mesures à la majorité les parents
donc décidé de quitter la salle en signe
de protestation ils ont été rejoints une
dizaine de minutes plus tard par les
membres de l'opposition de trappes
citoyens
faire payer les parents le périscolaire
et parallèlement dire qu'on ne fait plus
d'études c'est paradoxal parce que à
quoi va servir cet argent
d'un côté on va faire payer les parents
et leurs côtés on aura l'air le peu
qu'ils avaient et donc je trouve que
c'est assez paradoxal c'est dommage pour
les parents surtout pour ceux qu'ils
peuvent pas payer quoi justement je suis
concernée par cette décision et mes
enfants restent 15h30 jusqu'à 18h30 et
donc bg devoir payer et puis j'en ai pas
l'étude
voilà c'est dommage finalement ce seront
les enfants de familles privilégiées qui
pour payer les activités qui seront
proposées sans être sûr de la qualité de
ses activités d'ailleurs et les autres
vont se retrouver dans la rue on habite
à trappes
il faut de l'ambition pour nos enfants
pour tous mes enfants et seront réalisés
que ses enfants vont être dans la rue
moi je trouve ça inadmissible dans deux
écoles de la ville et personne en entend
parler alors on devrait faire l'étude et
les enseignants lorsqu'on leur demande
de faire de l'accompagnement éducatif ce
qui me remonte d'un conseil d'école
d'urbana on peut pas parce que ça
prolonge la journée de l'enfant et quand
on fait 40 e ou 7 heures 2 minutes
débute on prolonge pas la journée de
l'enfant ne prolonge pas la journée de
l'enfant bon coin quand même on est là
pour arranger les parents on est là pour
arranger les adultes on n'est pas là
pour arranger les enfants maudits suis
là pour les enfants la ville de trappes
compte 36 écoles primaires et
élémentaires la réforme des rythmes
scolaires a été mise en place en
septembre 2013 nous partons pour
versailles ou le centre hospitalier a
inauguré hier les nouveaux locaux de son
service de médecine nucléaire ça
l'honore mais surtout la technologie de
pointe elle la médecine nucléaire permet
de diagnostiquer de nombreuses
pathologies notamment des cancers
mélanie poquet et william tel coup de
jeune pour le service de médecine
nucléaire du centre hospitalier de
versailles depuis le mois de mai les
trois médecins travaillent dans leurs
nouveaux locaux avec du matériel de
pointe de gamma caméra et un tep scan
des appareils permettant un meilleur
accueil des patients en diminuant
notamment les délais d'attentes pour une
médecine particulière pour le multi
nucléaire en étudie tous les organes
loos le coeur le poumon
si vous voulez en utilisant différentes
des différents produits radioactifs pour
la tomographie d'émission de positons
pour le moment on utilise beaucoup la
cancérologie
mais on peut faire la neurologie dans la
maladie d'alzheimer on peut rechercher
des infections on peut étudier les
vascularite etc etc
ces locaux s'intègre dans le projet
maternité néonatologie scintigraphie et
réalisation pour un coût global de 48
millions d'euros dont 9 sont apportés
par l' agence régionale de santé mur en
béton plein protection en plomb pour le
personnel zones froides zones chaudes
la réglementation est stricte le zonage
est important parce que la zone froide
c'est la zone qui est accessible à
n'importe qui tout public qu'il y
accéder
les zones réglementées elles ne sont
accessibles qu'aux personnels qui est
habilité c'est à dire qu'il ya eu la
formation pour qui a les moyens de
radioprotection ou et qui a les
appareils de dosimétrie poursuivre sa
deuxième et riz et qui est formé au
poste de travail depuis plus d'un mois
le secteur table scan réalise 5 à 6
examen par jour le premier patient a été
accueilli dans le service le 12 mai nous
allons parler de sport mais de politique
également un petit peu à présent avec
alexandre joly bonsoir non j'avais sept
vice président délégué aux sports au
conseil départemental des yvelines mr de
huy également avant tout même de parler
de l'investissement sportif du
département des yvelines un mot sur la
candidature de paris aux jeux olympiques
2000 24 qui a été évoqué au début de ce
journal c'est officiel donc depuis
aujourd'hui
vous y êtes favorable ça peut avoir une
très bonne incidence sur le département
des yvelines qui sera associée avec le
vélodrome et le golf national
je pense je crois que vous avez souligné
l'essentiel en ce qui concerne les
infrastructures et le département va
soutenir cette candidature car je crois
que c'est une bonne chose lorsque l'on
voit ce qui a été fait par exemple même
si on le regrette que l'on ne nous soit
passé devant
quand on voit le résultat de londres on
peut faire je crois des jeux olympiques
sans être dans la démesure mais en
développement tout ce qui est transport
et qui profite à près aux habitants et
puis sur les infrastructures
si c'est à la fois économiques et
écologiques comme promis je crois qu'on
a tout intérêt à soutenir le réseau
matière du conseil départemental y aura
le soutien du conseil départemental le
président bédié est attaché parce que le
sport a aussi des vertus dont seulement
pédagogique mais elle elle ça peut être
aussi attractif pour un territoire
vous êtes venu nous parler ce soir
principalement de ce vote le 19 juin
dernier au département 5 millions
d'euros par an pour les équipements
sportifs
à quoi va servir cet argent dans les
grandes lignes en train de ils ont gagné
3,13 trois orientations et l'ensemble
représente plus de huit millions d'euros
quand on compte tout ce qui est
promotion et aide notamment patron
travaille aussi sur la rider cup
de golf alors voulez-vous parler sur
l'un des axes s'est très rapidement je
peux dire il ya sport avec les
collectivités locales dont celle aides à
l'investissement
ces 5 millions dont vous parlez il ya le
sport association l'aide aux
associations où ça représente quand même
un million deux cent mille
et puis la promotion du sport et toutes
les valeurs qu'il qu'il amène avec lui
alors sur cette partie effectivement il
ya 5 millions d'euros qui chaque année
pendant la durée de cette mandature qui
seront destinés au sport
donc ça veut dire que malgré que ça ne
soit pas une compétence obligatoire
le sport est considéré comme une allée
dire une valeur sûre en tout cas
nécessaire pour l'attractivité du
territoire
vous avez fait un choix différent du
bassin de saint quentin en yvelines par
exemple parce que l'agglomération à 50
ans c'est pas non plus une compétence
obligatoire pour les agglomérations a
décidé de faire quelques économies
puisqu'il faut en faire malgré tout en
coupant en réduisant en tout cas les
subventions pour la culture pour le
sport également en demandant aux
municipalités de remplir leur rôle en
tout cas mettre la main à la poche
vous faites un choix un petit peu
différent aujourd'hui pas d'économies
sur le sport fait des économies ailleurs
et alors bon on a on a recentré quand
même j'allais dire les besoins et on a
une approche globale
donc c'est la différence avec le plan
précédent le plan précédent sur dix ans
c'était 60 millions d'euros dans les
investissements wic à ce rythme là une
différence de 10 millions mais qui est
complètement été absorbé par ce qu'on a
fait à un moment donné et un effort pour
la réhabilitation ou la création de
nouvelles piscines donc le plan piscine
a été arrêté donc effectivement on peut
dire que l'effort s'est poursuivi mais
on quand je parlais tout à l'heure de
globalité
c'est vrai qu'il ya un aspect attractif
hormis tout ce que l'on peut savoir du
sport de ses valeurs de l'aide aux clubs
mais il ya aussi j'allais dire des
valeurs et un attrait économique pour le
territoire et en termes de développement
d'ailleurs on a fait une étude sans 128
communes sur 260 ont répondu donc c'est
assez précis où l'on a défini quels
étaient les besoins des collectivités
locales et donc c'est bien cette aide
et c'est bien vers ce
thor besoin les villes c'est à dire la
création dans des endroits où manque de
structures alors qu'il ya un
développement à la fois économique et un
nombre d'habitants qui croît il y à la
réhabilitation d'équipements anciens il
ya des besoins sur les intercommunalités
pour avoir j'allais dire des structures
intercommunales
donc c'est bien sûr tous ces axes là que
l'on a travaillé et sur lesquels nos
efforts vont se porter donc vous avez
raison mais n'a pas baissé le pavillon
ce qui concerne le sport et pour
bénéficier de ces aides les
collectivités les municipalités vont
devoir soumettre des dossiers présentés
les projets commencent à me sens tout à
fait dans leur blocage de cet argent
dans tout à fait les d'abord on
dématérialise au maximum donc il est
possible de candidates et là en
septembre octobre
en ce qui concerne les collectivités
locales pour les infrastructures et
octobre novembre
en ce qui concerne les clubs les
associations pour les aides différentes
sur le deuxième des trois volet du
triptyque je vous ai présenté tout à
l'heure donc d'une première partie sera
à partir de fin octobre
une analyse administrative pour voir si
ça correspond à l'état d'esprit de ce
que veut véhiculer le département et son
président pierre bédier
et puis ensuite il ya une deuxième
partie pour alors la première partie
administrative c'est pour voir si appelé
document la deuxième partie pour voir
effectivement quel est le fond qui est
donné et qui est comment faire des
priorités si on a hélas c'est plus
suggestifs non non c'est pas subjectif
c'est les thèmes que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure le développement le besoin il
est bien évident que si un collège et à
proximité bénéficient c'est un atout
supplémentaire puisque là ça fait partie
des compétences obligatoires et à ce
moment là la gratuité de l'équipement
peut aussi servir
et dire au collège donc non non c'est
sur des critères qui seront travaillées
deviez annoté par j'allais dire que le
service des sports et après la troisième
partie vers la fin de l'année des débuts
de l'autre qui est un jury dans lequel
il y aura à représentant du président du
conseil général
1 le vice-président délégué au collège
aux scolaires et le vice président
d'eads et sport quelqu'un qui est
travail pour le développement sur le
département donc pour la partie à
développement et globalité
et puis quelqu'un du service des sports
il ya des besoins importants aujourd'hui
en matière de sport matière
d'infrastructures sur le département est
ce qu'il ya une homogénéité aussi des
différents équipements et de l'accès au
sport pour tous alors il faut dire qu'on
est assez bien équipé il ya quand même
de 1600 équipements qui y sont recensés
sur le 2006 en club et 4000 équipements
qui sont recensés sur le et répartis de
manière homogène rang alors c'est il
faut dire qu'il ya des développements
qui se font de façon plus importante ou
des projets plus importants que ce soit
la vallée de la seine dans d'autres
endroits où une nouvelle population va
arriver et il y aura un faux création
d'équipements donc effectivement on va
combler là où il y a des faiblesses et
en même temps là où il ya du
développement
c'est pour cela je vous disais la
nouveauté c'est la proche globale
c'est-à-dire quand on a débuté il faut
effectivement des budgets qui sont plus
contraints il faut les utiliser de la
meilleure des façons c'est ce qui est
fait le sport se porte bien dans les
yvelines
en terme de licenciés c'est les 375
mille licenciés oui il avait renoncé à
badens jédir ile de france on est le
premier département sportif et vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure et on prépare
on a tous les ans le
paris-nice en cyclisme on à la ryder cup
là bientôt je vais dire qui est quand
même les dégâts à paris brest paris 7 et
des risées week-end de golf tout et on a
des belles infrastructures vous là vous
l'avez alexandre joly veut rester en
plateau encore quelques instants avec
nous il est question à présent dans ce
journal est des incivilités dans le
sport c'est une préoccupation prise très
au sérieux par quatre comités
départementaux ceux du basket de hand de
foot et de rugby
une journée de sensibilisation était
organisée au complexe boniface c'est à
elancourt doit jouer en 3 contre 3 sur
un demi terrain
on va donner la bad donc quand vous
marquez on donne la balle à l'adversaire
et pour repartir on repartira du trust
est là bas apprendre les règles d'un
sport que l'on ne pratique pas
d'ordinaire un des objectifs de cette
journée de sensibilisation orchestrée
par quatre comités départementaux
handball basket football et rugby
derrière ces ateliers le but perd donc
découvrir à des jeunes d'autres
pratiques sportives et surtout combattre
les incivilités beaucoup plus nombreuses
qu'on ne pourrait l'imaginer nous sommes
dans 10 sport collectif et que nous
avons pratiquement les mêmes
problématiques sur le que ce soit en
salle ou sur le terrain par rapport à
tout cet environnement agressions
verbales agression physique à gré sur un
ton de racisme ainsi de suite
et de temps en temps nous nous rendons
compte que ces agressions qui peut-être
pour le grand plus et que passent
inaperçus pour nous sont très néfastes
l'auteur n'est jamais punis parce qu'on
arrive à négocier
et là on voudrait arriver à un moment
donné à réparer la faute de celui qui a
été agressée dès qu'on engage une fille
et on n'a plus le droit de pigeons
une journée destinée en priorité aux
plus jeunes des sportifs et ce n'est pas
un hasard
nous constatons tous les jours et là ce
qu'il ya de plus en plus d'incivilités
au de violence au moins verbale sinon
physiques sur des matches de jeunes
c'est-à-dire des matches qui peuvent
concerner des bagages à main des minimes
voire une grotte plutôt sur des poussins
mais souvent ça vient du public et en
partie mais ça vient des parents
donc nous pensons que si nous arrivons
effectivement à endiguer cette
progression des incivilités chez les
matchs de jeunes nous pensons que dans
un deuxième temps ces jeunes qui vont
devenir adulte dans un deuxième temps
véhiculeront des valeurs d'esprit
sportif plutôt que des valeurs
d'incivilité une démarche entamée par
ces quatre comités départementaux depuis
2014 et qui pour l année prochaine
s'étendre à d'autres sports plus
individuelle dirigeants de clubs et du
14 et entraîneurs ont également été
invités à cette journée de prévention
des modules de formation leur seront
proposés mais tous l'affirment il n'y a
pas de solution parfaite
cette problématique des incivilités dans
le sport vous y êtes sensible également
au conseil départemental
est ce la troisième orientation vers
celle du développement et des valeurs et
c'est la raison pour laquelle on a
quarante sept comités départementaux que
l'on que l'on aide parce que l'ambiguïté
c'est que au sport pour certaines
personnes c'est on n'échappe à
l'environnement sociologique dans
laquelle on est mais en même temps le
sport
effectivement un moment on a tendance à
se relâcher les vire les qualités et les
défauts ont tendance à ressortir
mais le sport aussi lorsqu'on apprend
aux enfants à aimer le sport on apprend
à respecter les agréent on apprend à
respecter ce qui commence à aimer et
donc je crois qu'il ya des valeurs
éducatives très important techno sport
donc effectivement je crois qu'ils ont
non seulement ils ont raison du
département va les aider
merci alexandre joly vice président
délégué aux sports conseiller
départemental des yvelines
et puisque nous parlons du conseil
départemental cette polémique autour du
souhait de pierre bédier président de
cette instance de retrouver à la tête de
l'office hlm opievoy un office qui
l'avait dirigé 2,94 à 2005 et des
représentants là des locataires s'y
opposent il évoque la condamnation du
principal intéressé en 2008 pour recel
d'abus de bien social condamnation qui
serait un compas
cible légalement avec son élection les
représentants des locataires qui
craignent surtout le démembrement de
l'office hlm nous y reviendrons plus en
détail au cours de nos prochaines
éditions
la suite du journal avec le deuxième
volet de notre dossier consacré à
l'europe ce soir il est question de ses
missions de bénévolat en europe est de
l'apprentissage des langues des missions
développer dans le cadre du programme
sv le service volontaire européen il
existe plus de 160 organismes qui
participent en france
l'un d'entre eux est basée à saint
germain en laye
erasmus un dispositif qui vous parle
certainement un programme de mobilité
qui vous permet de partir en europe mais
il en existe bien d'autres
le svr service volontaire européen par
exemple concerne le bénévolat et le e71
des programmes qui s'adressent à tous
jeunes entre 17 et 30 ans et qui est
financé par l'union européenne via le
programme erasmus plus jeunes à ces
scores c'est un programme de mobilité
qui permet à tous jeunes de réaliser une
mission de volontariat entre 2 mois et
12 mois
on conseille
les jeunes d'effectuer un volontariat
plutôt de entre 6 et 12 mois pour avoir
véritablement une expérience dans un des
28 pays de l'union européenne mais
également de pays partenaires pays
voisins qui participent à ce programme
est l'objectif premier de ce programme
service volontaire européen c'est pour
le jeune de se mettre à la disposition
d'une association d'une structure
associative en europe dans une structure
d'accueil et ce jeune va pouvoir mettre
à disposition ses compétences et en
acquérir de nouvelles au contact de
cette structure d'accueil dans le cadre
d'un projet européen
le programme a été reconduit dans le
cadre de erasmus plus la nouvelle
programmation de la commission
européenne ce programme il date de 1996
donc il y à fort taux de réussite de la
part des jeunes qui partent en mobilité
dans le cadre du volontariat
les associations qui sont principalement
composée de bénévoles sont aussi des
quantités importantes pour
l'employabilité donc c'est très
important que les bénévoles soient
encouragés aussi par tous ces jeunes
volontaires à progresser dans leur
l'acquisition de compétences et je pense
que le toutou ces jeunes volontaires
apporte une dimension interculturelle ce
monde du travail
la maison de l'europe des yvelines
participe à la promotion de ce programme
le volontaire lui est nourri logé et
assuré tout au long de sa mission
margot 26 ans a eu l'opportunité de
réaliser un sdf pendant un an en espagne
à barcelone j'étais volontaire dans une
association
qu'ils s'appellent la fondation a émises
org c'est une association qui en fait
aide les ong à développer leur
communication sur internet c'est une
période qui m'a apporté beaucoup de
de créativité qui m'a donné confiance en
moi aussi et surtout qui a été un vrai
tremplin pour la suite en france quand
je suis rentré en france j'ai trouvé un
travail j'ai pu utiliser les langues que
j'avais apprise en espagne comme en
espagnol ça m'a permis d'avoir une
ouverture aussi sur sur l'europe de
m'engager bénévolement pour des
structures
le service volontaire européen en fait
juste que renforcer ma volonté de
travailler avec des personnes d'autres
cultures d'être d'être plus mobiles de
participer à des échanges en europe ou à
l'international
c'était vraiment une expérience
enrichissante et que je recommande
tous les jeunes ceux qui savent ce
qu'ils veulent faire plus tard et ceux
qui ont encore des doutes sur leur
orientation
pour les intéressés des réunions
d'information ont lieu tous les mois à
la maison de l'europe des yvelines
prochaine séance le 24 juin
nouveau volet consacré à l'europe dans
le journal de demain une compétition un
peu particulière pour terminer à présent
ce week end à rambouillet pour la
deuxième année la commune accueillait
une étape du championnat de france de
voitures à pédales une compétition qui
voit s'affronter une vingtaine de petits
bolides à propulsion humaine donc un
pagne à fleurs un crayon un pingouin
la fusée de tintin non vous n'êtes pas
devenu fou vous assistez à la neuvième
étape du championnat de france de
voitures à pédales ya un championnat on
a une note à la vitesse et nota
l'esthétique et le nec plus ultra c'est
d'avoir le combiné c'est à dire dit
esthétique c'est un vélo en fin de
compte mais allongée et à côté on a un
look et donc on est noté sur la vitesse
et sur le look est disons que au niveau
du championnat ya peu près 25 à 30
voitures qui se battent actuellement
trois heures de compétition les
concurrents s'affrontent parler de 2 ou
3 et toute la logistique qui va avec
stands aux couleurs de l'équipage et
mécano à l'affût on refait la voiture la
carrosserie tout l'hiver et après on
roule l'été avec via l'entretien la
voiture donc les pneus tout ça parce
qu'on fait quand même
quasiment 90 km par course on a une
moyenne de 30 km/heure donc les pneus ça
use là que la mécanique et tout organisé
par l'association dès commerçants et
artisans de rambouillet cette 9e étape a
vu l'équipe
lucky luke dégainé la première dans un
instant sur tv fils de 7,8 société
thématique de ce mardi le burn out quand
le travail nous fait craquer cette
édition est terminée je vous retrouve
demain mercredi aux horaires habituels
très belle soirée sur notre antenne